jusqu'au 3 septembre des oeuvres des 800
gagnants du concours divine
environnement sont exposés à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet on peut y voir
des maquettes ou encore des peintures le
thème cette année était la mare le thème
de l'année passée étaient nos amis les
mares car nous avons pensé qu' à travers
les mares se développer tout un
écosystème qu'il était important de
connaître et que sans doute quelques
fois quand on se promène en forêt on
n'est pas très attentif à ce qu est une
mare et j'espère que grâce à ce travail
qui auraient été effectuées on
comprendra tout l'intérêt des marques
dans l'écosystème l'écosystème mais
surtout l'écologie le but de ce concours
qui a duré toute l'année d'initier les
élèves âgés entre 5 et 15 ans à ce thème
et surtout de pouvoir s'exprimer
le but est de faire découvrir un thème
qui concerne notre environnement et nous
avons des thèmes extrêmement variés
puisque il ya eu les arbres il ya eu
aussi la question du patrimoine il ya le
patrimoine bâti ya eu les oiseaux et
après la mare un nouveau concours sera
mise en place l'année prochaine
le thème de celui ci nos amis les
prairies allez à vos croquis